hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to oh I'm
sorry I'm just trying to violently knock
out all memory of this god-awful movie I
just saw a kid in King Arthur's wart a
kid in King Louise cart a can't be off
his couch there we go no memory at all I
can't talk about movie if I came to
remember the title so it looks like I
don't have to review a kid in King
Arthur's Court there are movies that are
bad movies that are sinful and movies
that rape the fabric of space and time a
kid in King Arthur's Court is all over
with a bucket of shame and a mouth full
of writers diary and unless I can
quickly repress the memory of this movie
it starts the kid from American Pie Oh
looks like I had to review it so it
starts off with Merlin looking an awful
lot like Nick Nolte's mug shot calling
upon his magic to bring a brave knight
to Camelot to save his kingdom oh great
give it up right
bring me back tonight no no I said bring
me a knight not show me cutscenes from
Rookie of the Year so we see our main
character named Kelvin and no he's not a
ten-year-old with an imaginary Tiger but
he's pretty much on the same brain
length we see him at a baseball game
where it turns out he's not exactly the
best player oh god oh god
right oh why did I sign this kid up
again oh yeah cause I'm doing his mother
hit the ball keep your eye on the ball
cow oh and hitting it would be nice to
hasta LaVista fuller
copy like on that catchphrase I need you
I eat you all after refusing to hit the
ball three times in a row
Calvin is forced to take his seat where
his teammates rightfully make fun of it
what give me my bat as you wish your
highness
hey act like the ball isn't going to
write you and then you can talk back to
the players well it looks like even the
earth isn't fond of our hero as the
ground literally devours him and
swallows them whole well I sure hope
there's no baseballs down there we're
then transported to what looks like a
fucking red Ferris the sky shits out our
hero and drops him onto some
unconvincing medieval costumes here be
careful I think there's a baseball in
there it'll kill your family it turns
out that the kids stopped the robbery as
precious treasures were being stolen
from a very frail and pudgy looking King
Arthur find the brave man who followed
the Black Knight I would have taken
personally please thank the Lord Alaska
sure your highness did I let you down
the villain no because I don't have to
so Calvin is captured by the guards as
they're told that he should be brought
before the king Terry Kim took Kemp
aren't we in Camelot okay hello so they
taken to King Arthur to decide whether
or not Calvin is a threat but they
quickly discover the length right he
poses as to their lunches hey guys
where's the boys room I've been holding
it a third inning are we going hey don't
I get a phone call or something let me
give there are no phones in medieval
times
yeah there's electrics like that so
Arthur asked the boy a series of
questions to find out more about it
I tell me what is they call the upon Oh
lots of things
jerk off dickweed bane of my existence I
have a whole list but the boy seems to
amuse are throwing his two daughters
that wait a minute when did Arthur have
two daughters and is one of them kate
winslet where did you say you were from
holy shit it is it's Kate Winslet
may I suggest for up I'm a visitor from
Reseda a fortnight of training with
master Kane don't try to class up this
movie lady it's not rented your highness
yeah I don't mean to butt in here but
where's the round table Rowley
table you know were you and your Knights
have your meetings its rounds you gotta
look everybody in the eye no favorites
everybody's equal if you're good is
equal fastly the idea
oh so it's because of Calvin that we had
the infamous round table I see it must
have been mentioned in The Lost Worlds
too dumb for history I think it also
mentioned white Arthur always wears a
lobster pin but I could be loved so
Calvin gets friendly with the king's
daughter princess Katie where she shows
him a secret passageway because
apparently all guest rooms anzi her
passageways she shows him Merlin's old
quarters where all the swords armor
spells and everything else that look
made this movie a lot cooler are stored
that's just father's old sword old sword
that's Excalibur my dad doesn't know a
lot i watch a lot of CNN oh yeah
because they're always talking about
that guy stuff on CNN Balaam planned in
danger the economy is getting worse did
you know that King Arthur had a sword
named Excalibur more at 11:00 after
Katie leaves we see Calvin come across a
mystical toilet that apparently holds
Merlin for some reason what are you
doing here boy stand aside so I may see
my great warrior oh this is awkward I
hate to tell you this but I'm the only
one here something has gone horribly
wrong I think you can tell that just by
the title what am I doing here I brought
you here to save Camelot Arthur is in
trouble his kingdom has been shattered
plots are going nowhere scenes just
prattle on and die we need to do
something so even though they both share
the correct notion they cow
and as a loser he showed it to the train
where they tried to make him mature
Daniel Craig he's in this - oh god this
is like that desperate porno a celebrity
does before he becomes famous only more
painful and far less entertaining but
it's not just Craig Princess Katie it
turns out as a master of swordplay - oh
yeah because they were all doing that at
the time when we were always taught how
to use the sword in the dark ages that's
why they were considered just as equal
as men this movies as historically
accurate as a medieval times restaurant
there were no utensils in medieval times
hence there are no utensils at medieval
times would you like a refill on that
Pepsi God these things are a lot heavier
than they look on TV TV yes he comes
from the 90s isn't it funny yeah smells
like something died in here someone did
die there there come on Spamalot have
more dignity than this but as kelvin
discovers he's not exactly the world's
greatest fighter message boy huh oh I
cannot believe I fell for the oldest
trick in the book then again since I'm
here maybe the newest trick in the book
wow I can't believe I just read the
lamest joke in the world or since I'm
here the lamest joke in history
meanwhile we see Winslet do princessy
things like picking flowers and turning
down little creepy guys who happen to
have the Royal hots for her you're the
most exquisite flower in this garden
princess there's one major difference
between the garden flowers and myself
here in Alaska a rose will prick you but
I will do falworth I can't believe I'm
gonna be doing Hamlet after this after
that Calvin asked one of the local
blacksmiths if he can make him a pair of
rollerblades yeah I'm not kidding
a pair of rollerblades
I the circle builders themselves wait
who I the circle builders themselves
what the hell does that mean the circle
builders it's not like some sort of
medieval rock band I mean while you're
at it why don't you say by the square
makers of Antioch or by the triangle
tremors of trickle Street or by the
power of the parallelogram pounders oh
we're really mystical now so Calvin and
Katie go rollerblading through King
Arthur's castle wow that did sound uh
stupid as I thought it would if they
work their way back down to the training
room where Calvin it finally seems is
getting the hang of actually hitting
something but Lord balding skunk is
determined to make a mockery of Calvin's
achievements well if you've had enough
food fighting wooden man how do you
fancy taking on a real man for a change
look out he might have a baseball bring
the crystal balls you will use your belt
to hang yourself with because when I
come for you
you'll be was fine by us so in order to
celebrate his ball busting victory Katie
and Calvin share a meal together
beautiful but what is it Big Mac I made
some chicken McNuggets I didn't see any
raccoon testicles lying around
hahaha oh my god it just hit me I may
never see my family again my friends are
gone and I'm in a time period I will
never survive it oh well so Calvin and
Katie go riding in the forest when they
spot Winslet and Craig doing whoa hot
British sax I never thought the three
words would go together but whoa but as
those two share their love for one
another
Calvin tries his hand at this romance
thing as well
save me Oh patent you are a clever lad I
think she likes me
yeah that's why she kicked me most women
who like me kick me I'm a ladies man
however it turns out that Katie is in
love but judging by this scene we're not
quite sure to who you are in love little
wannabe see can't hide anything from you
can I I know it all too well myself are
you talking about Calvin or does it
always hurt this much sometimes it hurts
much worse am I the only one finding
this kind of hot
to become of our family Sarah I know not
but I will always look after thee
farewell bye
Oh son of a bitch my medieval must be
the sullen few things I see before I die
and then all the Sun it comes to those
don't buzzes I mean come on what kind of
statue Alana Susan can we possibly get
out of those two never swallow never
sure oh all right so there's no more hot
British lesbian sex Wow
four words I never thought I'd hear
together but Calvin does manage to get
the blacksmith to make him a bike yep
first of us the rollerblades now it's a
bike what is it
it's a mountain bike for God's sake how
many groundbreaking technologies can a
blacksmith make what is that it's a Ford
Focus with anti-lock brakes standard CD
mp3 player and new electronic stability
control neat huh
so the two of them decide to write their
bike and go on a picnic here we get to
see editing edits works as it literally
just dissolves in every single cut why
the hell are they doing that you usually
dissolve just to show a passing of time
I need to know what's going on his time
going by us they're talking I never knew
my mother that well I heard she was a
prostitute with crabs funny in seventh
grade I knew I had to wear diapers for
the rest of my life so it took a little
adjusting sometimes I just hit the wall
and cry out of nowhere and I have no
idea why so okay these two are
supposedly falling in love if you can
buy that as Calvin says goodbye to his
sweetheart at the door I haven't had
this much fun in my whole life I know
you're worried about your father
me too
I promise I'll do everything I can to
keep the Lascaux from screwing things up
you know you're right nice to the door
kid you really can hear her struggling
and mumbling for help princess oh I
haven't had this much fun in my whole
life I know you're worried about your
father yes that's all oh yeah wow you're
a great kisser
Oh God what an idiot so yeah the brave
y-your princess who has been taught
sword fighting all her life suddenly
can't use her fighting techniques on a
couple of guards this is a very common
case I like to call dumbass in distress
disorder this usually involves a strong
totally independent female who for the
first two acts of the movie kicked
everybody's ass and is a mighty force to
reckon with
but then near the end of the movie oh
that's the third act getting closer I
suddenly find myself becoming dumber and
less confident and now suddenly I'm in
danger oh if only there was a man around
to save me they never seem to succumb to
this strategically contrived illness so
they sneak her out under the cover of
daylight for some reason as lord i
shadow tells one sled that he has her
sister and the only way he'll let her go
is if she marries him you cannot force
me to marry you if you do not consent
then Princess Catherine will die how
could you see what I just did that I
make fun of your acting because I'm the
one who has a career after this movie I
was the villain neutralized when would
you ever be in a James Cameron movie
oh god I'm funny so Laura gay cloak
plans to pin the whole kidnapping on
Calvin but Calvin escapes as he tells
the King what's going on in please
within the hell she's been taken
prisoner it's impossible blasco's orders
but I dressed better - good with my life
even faked out played for a sucker your
chain has been royally pulled another
things I'm sure children my age say so
the King decides to help him out as
Calvin goes and hides sorry oh
I have some terrible news never mind me
I'm just a moving hunk of armor with a
kid's faith for our crotch don't waste
my time find the boy bring me his head
on my back I'm acting so Calvin thinks
up a plan he and the King dressed like
peasant so they can break into the Loren
ponytails fortress and save Kate yeah
that's a good plan or seeing how he's
the king maybe you just say arrest that
bastard bring my daughter back and have
this all fixed into an axe but the movie
decides this is more exciting as the
King discovers he's not as welcome in
his kingdom as he thought they'd find
out you're the king
you're dead meat don't understand
let's boogie cuz that's what kids say
right they say boogie get down to the
hammer time funky monkey I swear I'm
cool please tell me I'm cool ah yes
again this fearsome where your princess
can battle with a bow arrow and sword
but it's just so afraid of those pesky
dirty rats you mean while our two heroes
break into the fortress to save the day
quiet I think I hear my daughter pushing
out you wouldn't happen to have a key
would you I have something better lad my
father's not for a daughter oh well I
have a boys coordinates for a hot chick
let's see if that works
come but the guards arrive as the King
plans to rediscover his inner Knight
once more oh come on you can blow on the
old geezer IV fall over be careful
some of them might be carrying baseballs
God help you up there carrying baseballs
Jesus always works in the movie
oh yeah cuz the realism of this moment
totally made me forget that this was in
fact a movie that's a good the
filmmaking but Katie gets kidnapped
again as her hero's plea for her life at
the edge of a cliff stop that
well she flies like a bird no take me
please oh I'm afraid Rocklin bro
will not work this time you're wrong it
is the great equalizer what the hell oh
please that's mildly annoying gosh okay
first of all the laser on the disc man
can't be turned on unless the disc mad
is closed second how come when the night
falls he suddenly turns into a hand
puppet I mean did they have any effects
for this movie at all so our heroes
finally returned the princess back home
to be reunited with her sister oh yeah
kiss her dr. Oliver now I know what
you're thinking our things sister is
this the idea of them making out sick
nope hey there actresses first and
sister's second and that's good enough
in my porno fort so now it's time to put
that evil douche whore in his place
you're looking up extremely well your
highness
if you'll just excuse me I'll go and get
ready for the toilet what you're gonna
let him walk after all he's done you're
gonna let him walk after all he's done
even idiot knows this makes no sense the
people believed me to be a card and the
god sister Lilith of Alaska by that time
in light when the hour is now it'll nail
him yes well wait until he kills me in
my sleep murders my daughters it takes
his place on the throne and then get him
but all is not finished as there is
still a tournament to be had where the
winner gets to win Kate Winslet's hand
in marriage
so of course Lord unibrow enters the
tournament putting on his most
ridiculous power ranger villain suit you
could find
Daniel Craig gets in the tournament
think he can win the day but sadly he's
no match for a shiny piece of jewelry on
the bad guys helmet what a load up
question yes it's all part of the plan
he wins the tournament Mary's my
daughter rules the kingdom and then we
spring into action but Calvin thinks he
can get Craig back on his feet and keep
on fighting chicane how many fingers am
i holding up just a little off the top
keep the sideburn ah no doubt one of the
great James Bond moments bond James Bond
but come on team
shaken not stirred just a little off the
top keep aside burn though it looks like
Craig or someone who looks like Craig
has entered back into the tournament
will he be victorious
his chances look slim but somehow
shockingly the night stays on his horse
it keeps on writing so they go at it
again this time without that pesky head
holding it back the night wins the day
and who exactly was he all along what a
shock and a load of shit I mean by the
contest rules this makes no sense he
didn't fight anyone else so it defeats
the idea of a tournament this contest
Amidala boy and it turns out Lord Harry
brows has the exact same a family ah to
meet by ancestors but you lie my
ancestors ha ha turns out the mysterious
Black Knight shows up to save the day
this is the hero all the town's been
talking about who has been bringing them
food and money to save the people so
it's decided he should marry the
princess and just who does the Black
Knight turn out to be after all this
time
all right so you shall marry yourself no
it turns out she's allowed to choose
whoever she wants to marry so she wisely
chooses the only person will have a
career to this movie Daniel Craig so all
is one is Merlin transports Calvin back
to his normal time nothing I can say or
do to make you stay there are several
things you can do the big Meech day you
just won't do that
so Merlin transports him back and even
allows him to finally finish his
baseball game the way he wants to
getting rid of his ball phobia and
that's not slo-mo that's really how fast
you go and as a special twist the
princess and King are at the game - how
the fuck does this make any sense
did they ever mention if they
time-travel or if they're just
descendants of the original characters
who cares I don't movie's over run this
is the kind of movie you show your kids
when you want to punish them it's stupid
uninventive and just downright for my
only hope is I can still not get all
memory of this movie by hitting myself
on the head repeatedly with the complete
works of Shakespeare a cock in King
Arthur's catch and stole a long way to
go I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
it so you don't Blue's Clues